[Music]  well tonight we gonna party till the  body don't stop and the party don't stop  because it keeps on going nonstop gonna  party all night gonna keep this party  going cuz the party won't stop it's been  two straight days and the party still  going to three four five six seven days  and the party keeps going party  Friday night p.m. my friends in the back  on Friday night Phoenix most important  Memphis to perform in Vegas know Lincoln  loved it  [Music]  New York City LA Chicago  you said Billy San Diego Phoenix Austin  Fort Worth Boston Memphis temple  Portland biggest Tucson Fresno Akron  Tampa pitchford newer Plano Lincoln  loved or sale of date  [Music]  we'll just be partying all day ba hons  girls music dancing ever pd's and  headphones party party party party party  party party party  [Music]  so tonight we're gonna party till the  party don't stop  you